the european union is getting ready to
end pandemic era restrictions on
visitors from the united states eu
ambassadors yesterday agreed to consider
allowing non-essential travel
for american tourists even those who are
not vaccinated
era barnett is at washington's reagan
national airport for us errol good
morning
when might this happen hey there tony
good morning well not soon enough
tomorrow eu ministers will meet and
they've signaled they will approve
americans
and folks from seven other countries and
territories to get free reign
in the eu take a look at this map we can
show you that folks from these areas
will be able to travel throughout europe
without having to quarantine and
non-vaccinated americans may be part of
this deal
as well now we should note that each 27
member state can add its own
restrictions
in addition to what they're about to do
things like a negative coping test
all that you have to be vaccinated and
as much as it breaks my heart
england and the uk not a part of this
deal because they're no longer a part of
the eu they've got their own
complicated rules to follow good point
errol
why would uh eu countries recommend
lifting restrictions at this particular
moment in time
well you have a number of things
happening at once a europe-wide effort
to restore
tourism 400 billion dollars lost last
year because of the restrictions
over the summer and into this year you
also have airlines wanting to restore
international travel it's one segment of
the sector that has not
met pre-pandemic levels plus these
increased vaccination rates in the here
in the u.s
and in the eu one other tool they have
now in their arsenal
is this green digital certificate the eu
has developed this
it effectively proves that you've been
vaccinated that you've had a negative
covert test all that you've recovered
from the coronavirus each of these tools
now are in place so that the eu
effectively thinks
hey maybe it's time to get the band back
together again
tony maybe it's time errol thank you
very much